>>Stacy: Good afternoon.
Welcome.
I'm delighted to host Dr. Cornel West and
Mr. Tavis Smiley today.
Dr. West is a class of 1943 university professor
at Princeton University.
He's best known for his classics, Race Matters
and Democracy Matters.
From film to TV to radio.
From spoken word and of course, authorship,
Dr. West crosses all media, and, to communicate
his message.
TIME Magazine describes him as "one complex
dude."
[laughter]
A brilliant scholar.
Political activist.
Committed Christian.
And a soul brother to the bone.
Welcome Dr. West.
[applause]
>>Cornel West: Glad to be here.
Thank you for having me.
It's a blessing to be here.
Thank you.
>>Stacy: Mr. Smiley is President CEO of The
Smiley Group.
He co-hosts the late night talk show Tavis
Smiley and also has his own radio show on
Public Radio International, the Tavis Smiley
Show.
He too is a multimedia communicator.
Covering race, religion, politics, social
justice, and all of those topics in ways that
challenge our beliefs.
He is not only a voice for change but he is
an inspiration for our youth.
Because of the Tavis Smiley Foundation more
than 6,000 youth have been trained in leadership.
These two co-host a show together on Public
Radio International.
Called Smiley and West.
They both collectively have written 35 books.
Both have had New York Times bestsellers.
And they've finally come together to raise
awareness about a topic, which they coined
the "p" word.
Or Poverty.
Poverty in America.
Please join me in welcoming Tavis Smiley and
Cornel West to talk about "The Rich and The
Rest of Us."
[applause]
>>Stacy: They, we have a video that we wanna
show.
Do you wanna?
>>Tavis Smiley: Yeah, I think this piece is
called "I had everything."
And the short answer is that last summer Dr.
West and I took a poverty tour.
We got on a bus and went to 11 states and
18 cities across the country.
Trying to get a sense of what poverty had
really done to America.
What was the impact of the so-called "great
recession" on everyday people in this country?
Doc and I believe that poverty is the moral
and the spiritual issue of our time.
But it required us to do a little more research.
We wanted to get out on the road.
Give up a part of our summer, to try to see
what the new face of poverty looked like.
So for so long in this country, poverty has
been color coded.
So you think poverty, you think black.
You think poverty, you think brown.
But with the Census Bureau letting us know
that one out of every two Americans is either
in or near poverty, 50 percent of our nation.
150 million people are either in or near poverty.
Clearly the face of poverty had changed and
we wanted to see what the new face of poverty
looked like, to have a better understanding
of how we are to advance our work, Stacy,
about what poverty is, what it is not, how
to reduce it.
How to eradicate it.
So we got on this bus.
Again, 11 states, 18 cities.
Had a documentary crew in tow with me.
And we turned that tour into a week long special
on PBS.
So for five nights on national television,
on PBS, there were these short pieces.
These seven to ten minute pieces.
On each night about what we saw, about a particular
theme, particular subject matter, particular
aspect or angle of poverty.
And that these short mini-docs, if you will.
These mini-docs were then followed by extensive
conversation with experts about these particular
issues.
So this is a piece that aired on one of the
five nights of the PBS special.
Born of our poverty tour last summer.
The precursor for the book we're gonna talk
about today.
It's about seven to eight minutes.
It's called "I had everything" and I think
it'll give you a good sense of what we experienced
on the tour.
So.
Take a look.
>>Stacy: Roll the video.
[blues music]
>>Male Narrator: The largest economic institutions
were brought to their collective knees at
the government's doorstep, in search of salvation.
The bailout.
Wall street socialized it's failure on the
back of Main Street.
The resulting housing crisis and jobs crisis
fostered a poverty unseen in generations.
A poverty not just of inner city ghettos and
barrios, but of the suburbs, crossing all
racial lines.
Nearly one third of the middle class, mostly
families with children, have fallen now into
poverty.
[blues music continues in background]
>>Male speaker: Welcome Dr. Cornel West!
[applause and cheers]
>>Cornel West: Oh, what a blessing to be in
the heart of the blues land.
I've always considered myself a blues man.
The life of the mind, 'cause the blues ain't
nothing but a occupied graphical chronicle
of a personal catastrophe expressed lyrically.
[applause]
The blues is universal.
I don't care what color, what culture, what
city, what life.
Everybody has some catastrophe.
[audience whistles]
But the question is, what is your response
to the catastrophic?
Will it be love and justice?
Or will it be hatred or revenge?
And the blues says, it's all about the love
>>Male #1: [inaudible] This is the homeless
[inaudible]
>>Male #2: That's what we are.
We're the homeless guys at Freedom House.
You talked about the poverty.
That's what, you know, I had a job, I had
a family.
I had, you know everything a person's supposed
to have.
The car, the whole bit.
And I'm down to nothing right now.
You know I've been, like in retail for almost
30 years.
I was working for one of the major stores.
Who decided last year they needed to close
140 of their stores down.
All of a sudden everything was thrown out
from under us.
I worked with people that had been with the
company 30, 40 years.
A year or two left, people are getting kinda,
whatever, pensions.
You know the things they worked hard to be
able to have in their retirement.
People who only had like a year or so to go.
Lost all of that.
Because I didn't have the job I also lost
my home.
And because of losing my home, I had, you
know, my wife and I, I had to make sure she
was cared for, 'cause I couldn't, there wasn't
any way.
And so we split up.
And we've been separated for about nine months
now.
[blues music]
>>Cornel West: So much love.
When I hear BB King I laugh sometimes.
I sing about Christ.
You can feel the love when he plays Lucille
it's mixed with misery, but misery never ever
has the last word.
Even [unintelligible]
[blues music]
>>Tavis Smiley: Many Americans of all races,
colors and creeds are finding themselves in
poverty.
More children of all races colors sand creeds
from 2008 to 2009 joined the ranks of the
poor in this country than at any other point
in time in recorded data in the history of
this country.
A country for me is not a great nation unless
it takes care of its babies.
[applause and cheers]
>>Tavis Smiley: It takes care of its babies.
>>Male #3: The unemployment rate in Detroit
is 31 percent.
[boos and shouts]
That's a depression that's not a recession.
>>Cheryll Chambliss: I just wanna speak to
the fact that I've done like I did everything
that I was supposed to do over time.
I educated myself.
Educated my children.
Home ownership.
And I'm not unique.
I'm a person that has been laid off of my
job.
I've had my car repossessed.
And my home is up for sale.
My boss explained to me that he could hire
two 20 something's for my salary.
And that I could bring a lot to the situation
where people are looking for experience, that
I have over these last 30 years but they just,
kind of put me out to pasture.
[whistling, shouting, applause in background]
But I'm not ready.
It's devastating.
>>Tavis Smiley: 'Cause when she says that
she is the face of poverty, she is.
I've been saying, and Dr. West has been saying
consistently on this tour, that the new poor
in this country are the former middle class.
[shouts of agreement]
>>Cheryll Chambliss: There is poverty on so
many different levels.
Poverty like we've never seen before.
And there's such a, just there's so much greed.
At the top.
And so much corporate greed that, something
has to be done.
>>Rep. John Conyers: There are more poor white
people catching hell than there are black
people [inaudible]
[shouts from audience]
We are in a class war right now.
[shouts and cheers]
We are [inaudible].
It's already here.
They just didn't declare it.
[shouts and cheers]
[blues music]
>>Tavis Smiley: There was a white woman who
was standing on the sidewalk who was waiting
for our bus to pull up so she could read Dr.
West and me the riot act.
Riot act.
>>Female Protestor: I went to the Tennessee
Williams Festival.
Y'all are upsetting me.
You have chosen Columbus Mississippi.
This is not a poverty town.
>>Tavis Smiley: She didn't like the idea that
we would bring a poverty tour, and pull up
outside this big poverty tour bus.
You're stigmatizing our town.
>>Early Robinson: I'm a ex-military man.
Both lost our jobs.
Say, February.
Got to pawn cars, got to do various things
just to keep our home.
Strong, healthy, can do it all.
Got all kinds of skills.
Nobody just not hiring.
>>Tavis Smiley: You're husband and wife, both
lost your job in the same month?
>>Early Robinson: Same month.
February.
2011.
And trying to keep the house and all, and
both of our cars is pawned.
>>Christine Robinson: I'm not a talker.
'Cause I'm going to start crying 'cause I
get emotional.
>>Early Robinson: Don't do that.
>>Christine Robinson: Oh.
[laughter]
Like Early said.
He'd been cutting grass.
I go clean houses.
I have to work all the time to pay [inaudible]
off.
>>Christine Robinson: I've got my CEO license.
I can do just about anything.
I'm willing to do it.
But they cut us off the stamps.
Penalized us.
We make two dollars too much.
We're fighting foreclosure just like she said.
The life insurance for Early is gone.
Car insurance is gone.
The [inaudible] walked last week.
Gas gone out the house.
No one know how you live.
But like you said, have faith, pray.
And we have each other.
We have God.
And we just keep on going.
>>Larry Tate: See, Prairie used to just serve
the elderly and the disabled.
Now we serve everybody that need to serve.
This year, we had a budget of two million
dollars.
2012, our budget's going to be about 800,000
So that's limited all the services.
>>Tavis Smiley: From two million to 800,000
>>Cornel West: [inaudible]
>>Tavis Smiley: Not even half.
So that's
>>Cornel West: Less than half.
That's what you have.
>>Larry Tate: Yeah.
That was a cut that came from the federal
So you can see now, we're gonna have very
limited service.
2012.
Now when we're dealing with a big dish of
poverty.
So that's just gonna make things worse.
It just seems like to me that the government
has forgotten about the people.
And we need to put that emphasis back on the
people.
[blues music]
>>Cornel West: Columbus, Mississippi.
The birthplace of course of the greatest lyrical
playwright in the history of the country.
His major theme is those who escaped from
reality.
The engagement with reality.
The engagement with history.
And the engagement with memory requires an
engagement with poverty.
And so the blues coming out of Mississippi
is an engagement with history.
And engagement with memory.
It's a engagement with poverty and a resilience
against it.
Endurance.
Fight back.
And this is a love tour that fights back.
[blues music]
>>Stacy: Wow.
[applause]
[CW and TS talk quietly to each other]
>>Cornel West: Mm-hm-hm.
Thanks son.
>>Stacy: What a story.
I grew up in Detroit, Michigan, so as I was
watching this video, some of the comments
definitely hit home for me.
And poverty, not a secret that there's people
in this room who this is home for.
So we're delighted to have you come and talk
about what you experienced, and why this is
important for you.
A lot of the themes that came out in this
video and in your book talk about Dr. Martin
Luther King Jr and how, collectively, we are
not living out that dream.
Tell me more about what you mean by that.
>>Tavis Smiley: Mm.
Please.
>>Cornel West: First I just wanna thank you,
and thank Google for allowing brother Tavis
and I to be here.
Anytime I get a chance to spend time with
this high quality freedom fighter I've known
for 25 years, consider him my younger brother.
And I'm his older brother.
>>Stacy: Alright.
>>Cornel West: So anytime we get a chance
to spend time together, it's a beautiful thing.
And I wanna acknowledge too, the magnificent
work that Google does.
And we had met a group here at Google that
had a wonderful conversation.
They were telling me magnificent things taking
place here.
And my dear daughter Zeytun, who was a computer
wizard who's teaching me both about Google
and about other aspects of the computer.
>>Stacy: Good.
>>Cornel West: I want to acknowledge.
>>Stacy: Very good.
[laughter]
>>Cornel West: Oh yes.
But lets' start with brother Martin King and
Fanny Lou Hamer, that rich tradition that
Tavis Smiley and I have dedicated our lives
to.
Which is all about a quest for unarmed truth.
The condition of truth to allow suffering
to speak.
So we're concerned about the suffering of
all people of all colors.
All sexual orientations.
All religions and non-religions.
But human beings who really ought to be living
lives much more, of higher quality and dignity.
And also the unapologetic love.
We're quite explicit about talking about love.
That's why this really has been a love tour.
>>Stacy: Yeah.
>>Cornel West: And for us, brother Martin
used to say "Justice is what love looks like
in public."
So when you really love people, we have a
deep love for poor people, you can't stand
the fact that they're being treated unjustly
and unfairly.
And when you look at the relation between
poverty on the one hand and the distribution
of wealth, the wealth inequality that the
Occupy Movement rightly talks about.
We say we've got to bring a limelight to it.
Tavis's idea to have this poverty tour.
My only condition was we begin on a Indian
reservation with our precious indigenous brothers
and sisters.
>>Stacy: Excellent.
>>Cornel West: And we started down at the
Indian reservations.
You can look at America from a very different
set of lenses.
Look at it from 1492, World War I. been going
on ever since.
311 reservations now.
50 percent unemployment.
Levels of social breakdown and so forth.
Then we moved to brown barrios where our Latino
brothers and sisters deal with immigration
policy.
Then we went to the black ghetto.
Or we used to, you know, we on the chocolate
side of town.
Where we come from.
>>Stacy: [laughs]
>>Cornel West: But then also our white brothers
and sisters.
And our Asian brothers and sisters.
So to make it a holistic thing.
To keep alive the legacy of Martin Luther
King Jr. [inaudible]
>>Stacy: You spend a good amount of time in
the book taking us back.
And going back and looking at history.
And talking about how this is not a recent
issue.
Why was it important to do that?
>>Cornel West: Well one, because you have
to understand, America itself of course was
born of revolutions.
Revolution against monarchy.
But of course we still had mistreatment of
indigenous peoples and slavery.
So the US Constitution, pro-slavery document.
And practiced for almost 80 years.
Wonderful words on paper.
On the ground, slavery at work.
Then we broke the back of slavery.
Magnificent.
Democracy alive.
Expanding.
Deepening.
But here comes Jim Crow, slavery by another
name. and that's what the Civil Rights movement
was all about.
But now our present wrestling is, with oligarchy.
We got one percent of the population own 42
percent of the wealth.
The top 400 individuals have wealth equivalent
to the bottom 150 million fellow citizens.
That level of wealth inequality cannot sustain
a fragile experiment in democracy.
>>Tavis Smiley: Mm-hm.
>>Stacy: People in this room love data so
I think they probably like the last part of
what you said.
[laughter]
Tavis, the subtitle of this book is called
"The Manifesto."
>>Tavis Smiley: Mm-hm.
>>Stacy: Are you concerned, are you worried
about critics thinking that you're pushing
a liberal agenda?
And is that gonna get in the way of achieving
what you wanna achieve by writing this book?
>>Tavis Smiley: Yeah.
It's a good question Stacy.
I don't think this is about liberal versus
conservative.
It's not even about black versus white.
It's about wrong versus right.
And the question is, are we committed to the
best in and for every American?
I think that whether we're black or white,
Republican or Democrat, liberal or conservative,
educated or illiterate, urban or suburban,
we all want the same thing as Americans.
And that's simply to live in a nation that
is as good as its promise.
That's all we want.
Nobody's asking for more.
Nobody oughta settle for less.
We all ought to have the opportunity to live
in a nation that is as good as its promise.
The problem with America, as currently structured,
is that the gap between the possibility of
America and the promise available to every
American, that gap is too wide.
So the gap between the promise and the possibility
is too wide.
And it's ever expanding.
As I mentioned earlier, when you have now
50 percent of your people living in or near
poverty as Doc suggested a moment ago, that's
a catastrophe waiting to happen.
And we argue very aggressively and unapologetically
in the text that poverty threatens our democracy.
So if you are a liberal, if you are a conservative,
if you're on the Left, if you're on the Right,
and you love America.
And you care about preserving and protecting
our democracy, then poverty is going to have
to be addressed.
My reading of history suggests, and I haven't
studied this as much as Dr. West has, 'cause
he teaches this stuff, but my reading of history
suggest to me that there is no, there is no
empire in the history of the world that at
some point did not falter or fail.
Every empire at some point falters or fails.
And I don't know if it's our hubris.
Or our arrogance.
Our narcissism.
Our patriotism, which has now run amuck and
become nationalism.
I don't know what it is.
But for some reason we don't even wanna wrestle
with the fact that this democracy could be
on the precipice of something very very dangerous.
What we argue in this book again is that poverty
is the moral, the spiritual issue of our time.
And if you don't wanna put it in moral terms,
in spiritual terms.
If you wanna take it out of the body politic,
the fundamental point is, that democracy as
we know it is unsustainable if we let this
divide continue to grow.
>>Stacy: And highlight for us you talk about
poverty.
A lot of times people think of the homeless
person on the street who's done something
bad, or is ill.
But you reframe it.
To talk about this new poor.
Or the near poor.
>>Tavis Smiley: And that's what this video
we saw is all about.
Trying to let people see what the new face
of poverty is.
We were just in New York a couple of weeks
ago.
I for the first time in my career, moderated
for PBS and for C-Span.
A panel of all women.
It was an all woman panel of experts talking
about the issue of poverty vis a vis women
and children.
Something is wrong with a nation that allows
its women and children to fall faster into
poverty than any other segment of the population.
That's where we are right now.
Women and their babies are falling into poverty
faster than any other group of Americans.
And so, it's important for us to see the faces
of these Americans.
Of all races.
Of all colors.
Of all creeds.
I won't repeat what Dr. West said earlier.
But he gave you a good sense, in the back
of the book, we laid out the poverty tour
that we took.
There's a wonderful appendix in the back of
the text that lays outóand when Doc and I
first thought about it, we weren't sure we
were going to put that in the book.
But the more we wrestled with it, our wonderful
editor, Cheryl Woodruff, decided we should
in fact put this in the book.
Because she said "People need to know where
you went.
And who you saw.
And what you experienced."
There are some wonderful narratives that we've
woven through the book.
But we wanted people to look at a snapshot
of what the tour was all about.
So in the piece you just saw a moment ago.
That white brother you saw in that piece,
he's not just white.
He's a military veteran.
That whole room as you saw was a room full
of military veterans.
Something is wrong with a nation that allows
military vets to put their lives on the line
for our freedoms, and they come home and they
can't find gainful employment.
There's something wrong with that.
And so the fact that he and his wife had to
split.
There was nothing wrong with their relationship.
They just couldn't make it together.
So they had to separate so that both of them
could try to survive.
And very quickly, what you saw him basically
saying, what I took from what he said that
night, and Doc and I saw this repeatedly throughout
the tour, is that there are so many people
that are wrestling with poverty.
And it's so egregious and it's so widespread
across the country that people are no longer
concerned about their homes.
They've lost their homes.
They've been unemployed for two or three years
some of them.
They've lost their 401K.
They've lost all their savings.
They're beyond the embarrassment in front
of family and friends that they've been unemployed
for so long.
But you know what they're trying to hold on
to?
Their dignity, Stacy.
They're fighting to hold onto their dignity.
Because as everyone at Google here understands,
there is dignity in work.
There is dignity in our labor.
And when you don't have an opportunity to
work to use your God-given skills, then your
dignity is threatened.
And then you start to wrestle with your own
humanity.
And when half of the country is wrestling
with that, now you see why we say that this
is threatening to our very democracy.
Now you see why Dr. West says all the time,
and we lay it out in the text, that this is
a matter of national security.
When you start having half the population
wrestling with these kinds of issues.
>>Cornel West: Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm.
>>Stacy: You've both been pretty outspoken
that the current administration, and even
as we go through the Republican primaries
have either ignored using the "p word" saying
poverty.
Or used it in ways that aren't uplifting in
your mind.
And that there's a responsibility that's lacking.
Why do you feel so strongly about that and
what exactly is lacking in your mind?
>>Tavis Smiley: You said something about Obama?
>>Cornel West: A little bit.
>>Tavis Smiley: [inaudible]
[laughter]
>>Cornel West: No, I have a great love for
my dear brother President.
But brother Tavis and I believe in protect
him against vicious right wing lies and respecting
him as a human being as President.
And correcting him because we love poor people.
We love working people.
And I think any President, any color, must
be accountable in that sense.
But I think part of it has to do with the
fact that brother Tavis and I come out of
a tradition that says that there's a difference
between success and greatness.
See, success is a beautiful thing.
Material prosperity can be magnificent if
you know how to use it, don't allow it to
devour your soul.
Having status and title and wealth can be
fine too.
But if one is well adjusted to injustice,
then you could be successful and not great.
>>Tavis Smiley: Mm-hm.
>>Cornel West: See greatness has to do with
what is the quality of how you treat other
people?
What's the quality of your service to others?
I'm a Christian, so it's "the least of these"
right?
Our Jewish brothers and sisters gave a great
gift to the world.
Prophetic voices.
Amos and so forth.
What you do to the least of these is the measure
of your greatness.
So don't tell me how much money you've got.
Don't tell me how big your crib is.
I wanna know what the quality of the love
and service you have, especially to those
catching hell.
The weak and vulnerable.
But that's the legacy of Martin as well.
We've been shaped by that.
So when I look at any President, I wanna know,
well what is the quality of your service to
the least of these?
Now we look at the Administration and we see,
well, often people say "Well, poor people
are individuals who have bad flaws and make
bad judgments."
I say "That sounds like some investment bankers
I know."
[laughter]
Flaws, bad judgment.
What do they get?
Bailouts.
Individuals, flaws, bad judgment.
Pull yourself up by your own bootstrap.
Deal with the consequences of your own failure.
This is a country that rewards success.
But if you're not successful and you go under,
you have to take responsibility.
OK, if that's true then let's play the game
by one set of rules.
You can see the hypocrisy setting in.
So when I looked at the Obama Administration.
I saw Tim Geithner and Larry Summers and others.
I said "My God, they don't have a history
of being highly sensitive to the suffering
of poor and working people.
They're Wall Street extensions."
You know, worked on Wall Street.
A very intimate relation with Wall Street.
Wall Street got that friendly treatment you
see.
And we make this point in the book.
Well, where's the investigations of Wall Street
insider trading, market manipulation?
We know Jamal and Leticia get caught with
a crack bag on the corner, they're going to
jail.
Was there criminal activity on Wall Street?
My hunch is--
[laughter]
Let's have the investigation.
Let's see whether they violated the law and
so forth.
So I see the Obama administration early on
too cozy with Wall Street and that was made
the point in terms of Main Street.
Now when he does wonderful things we applaud
him.
Health care extended for children?
Magnificent.
What was the Lilly, uh?
>>Tavis Smiley: Lilly Ledbetter.
>>Cornel West: For the sisters of our color?
>>Tavis Smiley: First law he signed.
Great decision.
>>Cornel West: Beautiful.
Beautiful.
But when he's turning his back to poor and
working people, we hit him lovingly.
[laughter]
Not just him.
But the whole Administration, you know.
>>Stacy: And then that's fair.
>>Cornel West: Absolutely.
Because we have a system where oligarchs really
rule both parties in place.
Republicans deeply conservative with oligarchy
rule.
Democrats, neo-liberal, but oligarchy rule.
Both tied to big money.
Who speaks for poor people on K Street?
13,000 lobbyists.
Wearing Red Element.
That's about it.
Some churches.
Some mosques.
Some synagogues that are prophetic.
We're not talking about the Constantinian
ones, who are well adjusted to the oligarchy
rules.
>>Tavis Smiley: And I think context here is
very important.
Most people miss this.
Four years ago when we were in the last campaign
for the White House with Mr. Obama, Mr. McCain.
Three presidential debates.
The word "poor" or "poverty" does not come
up one time in three presidential debates.
>>Cornel West: That's right.
>>Tavis Smiley: We all recall the economy
was tanking at that point.
We were headed into the so called Great Recession
at that moment.
The word "poor", "poverty" doesn't come up
in three presidential debates.
Obama doesn't utter it.
McCain doesn't utter it.
The moderators in those three debates don't
even ask about it.
Fast forward four years and nobody except
Wall Street bankers, are better off now than
they were four years ago.
Poverty abounds.
50 percent of us are wrestling with it.
You have the perennially poor.
You have the new poor.
As I said earlier, the new poor are the former
middle class.
And you have the near poor.
Folk who are just a paycheck away.
That's again, 150 million of us.
Half of us wrestling with poverty.
So we can't have another campaign for the
White House, Stacy, where the issue of poverty
doesn't get addressed.
We raised this issue with Mr. Romney.
He wants to suggest that we're playing the
politics of envy.
That's nonsense.
Nobody poor is jealous or envious of wealthy
people.
People just want an opportunity.
Want a chance to work.
They want their dignity.
They wanna revel in their own humanity and
that of their loved ones and family.
So it's not a politics of envy.
But we can't have another campaign where this
issue doesn't get addressed.
We are out here now, unapologetically, with
humility, to put this issue on the agenda.
We're not the only ones.
But to raise this issue higher up on the American
agenda.
So this time around, we don't go through another
campaign where this issue doesn't get addressed.
Thankfully Occupy is back.
It's the Spring.
And they're gonna be in full force.
So I think this time we're gonna see a different
conversation than we saw four years ago.
But we can't, our democracy again cannot survive
us putting our head in the sand and ignoring
this issue.
Particularly in a presidential election year.
So Doc is right.
It's not just the Democrats.
Democrats, Republicans.
Nobody wants to make this an issue.
We said in the book that there seems to be
in Washington right now a bipartisan consensus
that the poor just don't matter.
A bipartisan consensus that poverty is just
not an important enough issue to address.
And that's what sort of troubles us.
>>Cornel West: Mm-hmm.
>>Stacy: So you talk about some past presidents.
Johnson, Truman, Roosevelt as people who came
in with their Administration and did something
about poverty.
What impressed you about what they did?
What can the current Administration or a future
Administration learn from that?
>>Cornel West: Mm. well, Tavis always makes
the point that each Administration has to
be pushed.
And he's right about that.
LBJ was pushed by the social movements of
the 1960s.
Both the Civil Rights movement, the Trade
Union Movement.
Also religious people who were concerned about
the plight of poor people.
And so the, went from 22 percent to 11 percent,
in terms of poverty rate.
Within ten years with LBJ's program.
Especially the impact on the elderly.
Major investment.
And that's what we're calling for.
We need to shift from this discourse about
austerity and cuts.
And need to talk about investment.
Infrastructure, research and development for
technological innovation.
But especially for jobs with a living wage.
Job training centers.
And we really know what to do.
Paul Krugman makes this point in his recent
point, in this depression now.
We know what to do.
We just don't have the will to do it because
again, the political system is broken down.
It's become an instance of legalized bribery
and normalized corruption.
An it's hard to get the voices of poor working
people hear given that hemorrhage that's taking
place and in the mean time, our bridges are
collapsing.
Educational system is collapsing for working
and poor children.
And more and more this wealth inequality is
escalating.
>>Tavis Smiley: If I may add to that very
quickly Stacy.
>>Stacy: Sure.
>>Tavis Smiley: In the back of the book, the
last chapter of the book is called "The Poverty
Manifesto."
The book starts with a portrait of poverty.
It's important for us to understand how we
arrived at this place.
We start with a portrait of poverty and then
the next chapter is, talks about the poverty
of opportunity in this country.
And then we talk about the poverty of affirmation
and the poverty of vision.
And the poverty of courage.
And the poverty of imagination.
And we walk through these various chapters
under these kinds of things, weaving this
narrative.
What we think oughta be done and how we address
this issue and what hasn't been done quite
frankly.
At the end of the book there is the appendix
about the tour that we took.
But beyond that the final part is this poverty
manifesto.
Where, to your question more expressly, we
lay out a dozen things that we think need
to be done to get serious about reducing and
eradicating poverty in this country.
So there are 12 specific ideas at the end
of the text that we think we ought to as a
nation take seriously.
One of those ideas is the calling of a White
House conference on the eradication of poverty.
I mentioned earlier the power the President
has with just a pen.
The first thing that President Obama did the
minute he got inaugurated on those steps.
And we all watched and cried and celebrated.
He walked inside.
>>Cornel West: I'm not sure all of us did.
A significant number of fellow citizens did.
We did.
But we had a lot ofó
>>Tavis Smiley: Lot of people didn't.
>>Cornel West: brothers and sisters, hard
to adjust to that.
>>Tavis Smiley: I did.
[laughter]
Some folks still have a hard time with it
four years later.
>>Cornel West: That's right.
That's right.
We pray for them.
They just [laughs]
>>Tavis Smiley: I take that loving correction.
>>Cornel West: [laughs] They got challenges.
>>Tavis Smiley: But he walked inside and signed
Lilly Ledbetter which is again what should
have been done a long time ago.
With respect women in the work place.
What we are suggesting.
Not suggesting.
Calling for in this text, on this list of
12 things.
Is that the next President, as his first official
act, Mr. Romney, Mr. Obama or somebody else
that we don't know of at this moment.
They oughta after inauguration, through Presidential
order, through executive order, establish
a White House Conference on the eradication
of poverty.
Bring in all the poverty experts into the
White House for two or three days and let's
develop a national plan.
Not a band aid.
Not a quick fix.
But a national plan.
This ain't rocket science.
As Doc said, it's not a skill problem, it's
a will problem.
But bring the experts together.
You know there are all kinds of plans right
now that exist for how to eradicate, how to
reduce poverty in this country over ten, 15,
25 years.
Catholic Charities has one.
Jim Wallace at Sojourners.
Jeffery Sachs at Columbia.
Um, these programs these plans exist for how
to reduce poverty significantly in this country.
There are other countries that have done this.
We just have not had the kind of leadership
since President Johnson, that you raised,
Stacy.
Had that kind of Presidential leadership,
and that covers Republicans and Democrats,
so we're not trying to cast aspersions or
demonize Mr. Obama.
But we need that kind of leadership from the
top down.
That kind of bully pulpit that the White House
offers.
The President to make poverty a priority in
this country.
And finally again, echoing what Dr. West said
that great Presidents aren't born, great Presidents
are made.
They have to be pushed into their greatness.
So there is not Abraham Lincoln without Fredrick
Douglass pushing him.
There is no FDR without A. Phillip Randolph
pushing him.
There is no LBJ without MLK pushing him.
So those of us who care about the future of
this democracy and who understand that poverty
again, threatens that very democracy can not
be afraid.
We gotta find the courage, the conviction,
and the commitment to push all of our leaders
to make poverty a priority.
>>Stacy: So who is the push gonna come from
for us today?
>>Cornel West: People sitting in this room.
>>Tavis Smiley: And watching on YouTube.
>>Cornel West: And watching on YouTube.
Absolutely.
People of good conscience.
With courage.
Who want to make the world a better place.
Who are deeply concerned about injustice.
Deeply concerned about unnecessary social
misery.
And we're, we are witnessing that.
There is a democratic awakening that's taken
place.
Not just in America.
Tunisia, Egypt, Spain, Greece, and so forth.
Your example of Chile.
>>Tavis Smiley: Mm-hmm.
>>Cornel West: To go from 40 percent poverty
to eleven point five percent poverty.
That's major.
The wealth inequality is still a challenge.
But that's major.
We can learn something and that's a situation
which we in the United States often view ourselves
as out ahead of other people.
That's part of our American exceptionalism
you know.
God winks at us and closes God's eye to other
nations, you know.
Now we know that's a lie.
But we, we like to believe that.
We're free and democratic 'cause we fight
to keep it free and democratic.
We can lose it.
The younger generation can lose it.
If you don't fight.
You see.
But it's gonna come from everyday people.
It's gonna come from ordinary citizens who
wake up and say "Look, our priorities are
warped."
We came up with half a million dollars, a
Marshall plan, for jails and prisons in the
last 25 years.
But we say when it comes to education, we
don't have the money, gotta cut.
Jobs, don't have the money.
Housing, don't have the money.
Comes to war, Iraq, Afghanistan, trillions
of dollars we either found or went in debt.
The priority.
And brother Tavis is right.
He says poverty is a matter of national security.
State of emergency.
When it becomes a priority, we follow through.
We execute.
>>Stacy: So I know people in the audience
have questions, if you can queue up at the
mic, as I ask one more question.
Priorities.
In your plan, your 12 point plan, you actually
talk about women and children as being the
priority.
>>Cornel West: Absolutely.
>>Stacy: Tell me more about that.
>>Cornel West: Women and children first.
I think probably one of the saddest features
of the United States today is that the younger
you are, the more likely you are to be poor.
In the richest nation in the history of the
world, 23 percent of our precious children
of all color, live in poverty.
40 percent are red.
Never forget our indigenous brothers and sisters.
39 percent of brown children live in poverty.
38 percent of black children live in poverty.
Now that to me is just a moral abomination.
It's an ethical obscenity.
That that could be the case.
You know what I mean?
Finland got three percent of their children.
It's no accident they're number one in education.
You see?
They have a commitment to education.
Teachers, a whole culture of equity and shared
responsibility.
And their teachers, the major graduates of
the universities, become teachers rather than
investment bankers.
But of course they only got five and a half
million, so they don't have to rule the world
the way the United States often views itself
as.
No military commitment and so forth you see.
But a different kind of culture.
And we can learn something from Finland without
imitating them.
We're still quite distinctive in our own ways
you see.
But women and children first.
And I think that if we can get that out in
public and make that more visible and as Tavis
says, more and more it's not just black and
brown faces on poverty.
'Cause it's been color coded for a long time,
you see.
>>Tavis Smiley: And the irony, I might add
real quick, Stacy, the irony of it is, and
obviously in a campaign for the White House
the issues change daily.
Sometimes they change by the hour.
But every one of us in this room and on YouTube
right now knows that one of the great debates
right now over the last few days has been
whether or not there is in fact a war on women.
And should Ann Romney have gone to work and
what does it mean that she didn't go to work.
How many nannies did she have.
And what about the rest of women.
And we're in this debate.
Or at least a pseudo debate about women in
our society.
With regard to their economic status.
Their economic condition.
And their economic future.
But we still haven't gotten even in that debate
to the real issue.
Nobody on the Democratic side, nobody on the
Republican side has said that women and children
must be first.
And women and children, oftentimes the weak
and the vulnerable are falling faster into
poverty than anybody else.
So we get all these nonsensical ridiculous
quite frankly stuck on stupid debates about
nothing and that's what in part, presidential
campaigns are.
It's about point scoring and trying to play
to your base and the stuff that we all know
make up presidential campaigns.
But again, this is why you can't go through
another process like this.
Where the facts are not placed on the table.
And people aren't forced to address what those
facts really are.
So whether you're Mr. Obama.
Mr. Romney.
Or anybody else.
What are we going to go about the fact while
we debate this other stuff, that women and
children are catching the most hell?
What are we going to do about the fact that
Doc said just a moment ago.
And that just, every time I hear him say that,
and we write about this in the book.
But every time I hear that statement that
the younger you are in America the more likely
you are to be poor.
That goes against the whole notion of the
American Dream.
That goes against what every young person
I'm looking at right now here at Google is
all about.
You wanna make a difference.
You wanna make a contribution.
But let's not be naive here.
You want your piece of the American Dream.
You want your chance at raising a family.
You want your chance at home ownership.
You want your chance.
And there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that.
But how do we go, how did we arrive at this
place?
Of being a nation where again, the younger
you are, the more likely you are to be poor.
Put another way, too many of our children
are being forced to surrender their life's
chances before they ever know their life's
choices.
And that oughta be unacceptable in this country.
>>Cornel West : Mm-hm.
>>Stacy: Let's take some questions.
>>Male #1: Thank you Stacy.
My name is Michael Peggs.
I wanna thank both of you for being here an
particularly Dr. West.
For my brother in the house known as Alpha
Phi Alpha Fraternity Incorporated.
>>Cornel West: Oh-six, oh-six brother.
>>Male #1: And we appreciate you.
>>Cornel West: Oh, don't start on me.
Oh-six, oh-six
[laughter]
In the house.
>>Tavis Smiley: We Kappas ain't gonna have
that today.
>>Cornel West: In the house.
On King, Dubois, Duke Ellington.
>>Tavis Smiley: La, la, la, la
>>Cornel West: [inaudible]
>>Cornel West: I don't claim apology.
OK, I know you got a question.
>>Male #1: OK, I was traveling back from New
York yesterday on the flight, rereading "The
Miseducation of the Negro" by Dr. Carter G.
Woods.
And I was reminded that education is really
the paramount means for uplifting the people.
And whether pragmatic and practical, or classical
and traditional, education really has to prepare
you to make a living for yourself.
And that was really his second theme in the
book.
The importance of earning a living.
And I'm wondering if our current state of
poverty is a result of our inability to make
a living.
Some would imply it's a individual responsibility.
Or something larger.
>>Cornel West: Yeah, it's a deep question.
I appreciate the question.
The Greeks have a wonderful word called "paideia."
P-A-I-D-E-I-A.
Which means "deep education."
Not the same thing as cheap schooling.
Deep education.
Learning how to die.
Criticizing yourself.
Wrestling with yourself.
Examining yourself.
And then being a citizen.
Somebody who can actually be self-determining
in that way.
See, cheap education is just gaining a skill,
becoming a consumer, and being a spectator.
Not the same thing.
It might even plug you into the job.
Of course so many jobs these days are low
wage for the most part.
But it's the deep education that's at the
center of a democracy.
Not cheap ed, cheap schooling might be tied
to the market and so forth and so on.
But there' s got to be some balance between
the market that is open enough for people
to be able to allow their talents to flower
and flourish, and then public space.
Common good.
So it's not just about the private gain.
It's something that holds us together.
Glue that holds us together.
And deep education, public education at its
best, historically has been that.
But our priorities are warped.
Here again.
You know.
And that's part of our challenge.
>>Tavis Smiley: We could have a debate very
quickly about which came first, the chicken
or the egg.
That, which came first education or poverty.
Because their inextricably linked, the two.
Without having the debate about which one
impacts which, in which direction.
What we saw on this tour.
We spent a lot of time with children on this
tour.
And we saw children in your hometown in Detroit,
who come to school and they can't concentrate.
And you know why.
They haven't had anything to eat.
Their living conditions are deplorable.
Again, we didn't just see this in Detroit.
We saw this around the nation.
But the link between education and poverty
is well documented.
Everybody agrees on the Left and the Right,
without access to a quality education, then
you're much more likely to live a life of
poverty.
And so we take this issue without belaboring
the point.
We take this issue head on in the text.
But again, something is wrong when kids you
know, we've been working with a program called
Feeding America.
And the numbers of children who go hungry
in this country every day.
The increasing rates of food insecurity.
It's hard for a kid to go to school and concentrate
and focus when there's so much lacking at
home.
Here again, women and children falling through
the cracks.
>>Male #1: Thank you, thank you.
>>Cornel West: Absolutely.
>>Female #1: So the fact that you know, this
room isn't overflowing out the building to
me, reflects the fact that the elite really
don't prioritize poverty.
And people in this room are obviously, our
colleagues and neighbors, are part of the
one percent.
So how do you recommend that we, even the
most liberal of my colleagues and neighbors,
their extended social circles.
They consider themselves liberal but poverty,
as you well know, it's not at the top of their
concerns.
You know they're more concerned about internet
privacy or climate change.
And plenty of other things but poverty just,
isn't in their top three, five, ten.
>>Cornel West: Mm-hmm.
>>Tavis Smiley: [chuckles]
>>Female #1: So what do you recommend we do
to educate the people that we are in close
contact with who are the, you know, the people
who are in power in this country?
>>Cornel West: Now, we're trying to see to
it that within the next two to four or five
months, many of your friends will not only
be talking about it but will have their conscience
awakened.
Because a lot of times it's a matter of exposure.
A lot of times they tend to view what's going
on in the corporate media.
Which tends to have a very truncated framework
in regard to what's going on in the nation.
'Cause they've got a bottom line too.
So there hasn't been a lot of talk about poverty.
Lot of people in America didn't know that
there is such a thing as arbitrary police
power in poor communities.
Until Treyvon Martin came.
See, I mean, "Oh my God, that's still going
on?
In 2012?"
You don't say.
[laughter]
But we all have our own bubbles.
And people can't be in contact with everything
at the same time.
But when there's a major stress, the way Occupy
stresses wealth inequality, corporate greed.
People start talking.
"Oh my god, that does make sense.
That's true.
Look at the stories.
Newspapers are talking about it."
And I think we haven't seen this in America
really since John Atwoods tried to pull it
off.
But then he had his problems.
God bless him.
[laughter]
But it goes back then to Martin King and Dorothy
Day and Rabbi Abraham Joshua Heschel, and
the others in the 60s, the Thom Haydens and
others who were trying to raise this issue.
But now I think it's coming back and so I
think more of your friends.
And again, not limited to liberals.
But we're talking about centrists, conservatives.
Anybody who cares about other people's suffering.
I don't think liberals have a monopoly on
caring.
At all.
Even though thank God a number of them do.
But I think there is going to be a real renaissance
and I hope I'm not naive about this.
You don't think I'm naive about this?
>>Female #1: Well, thank you.
>>Tavis Smiley: I would never call you naive.
>>Cornel West: I appreciate that.
>>Tavis Smiley: No, no.
Thank you for your question.
>>Female #2: Hi, my name is Nava.
Thank you both for being here.
I, Dr. West, you referenced the prison system
earlier in your conversation and I'm just
curious to find out your insights around the
connection between poverty and prison.
>>Cornel West: Ah.
>>Female #2: and if you think that a major
overhaul of the prison industrial complex
is necessary.
If so, why?
>>Cornel West: Well, I appreciate the question.
When we make reference to that magnificent
text by our dear sister Michelle Alexander,
"The New Jim Crow."
And I was actually blessed to write a forward
to the paperback.
It provides a full fledged answer to your
question.
It has something to do with the war on drugs
and why it is that the war on drugs is disproportionately
targeting chocolate sides of town.
13 percent of young white brothers and sisters
on the vanilla side fly high in the friendly
skies.
13 percent of black and brown fly high in
the friendly skies.
62 percent of convictions, chocolate.
Black.
Brown.
Poor.
You see.
And so you go from 300,000 about 30 years
ago to two point four million today.
And again.
Not just a matter of priority but socially
neglected.
Economically abandoned.
Under intense police surveillance.
That's black and brown poor people.
Not even black and brown middle class people.
'Cause we know Jack and Jill black brothers
and sisters going to jail the same level as
Jamal and Latisha on the ground, the poor.
We have different kind of black leadership.
And I love my Jack and Jill brothers, don't
get me wrong.
But it's the class question.
How deep is your love for poor people?
No matter what color.
And think about an America, in terms of our
priorities.
I mean we have come up with now these drones
that can drop bombs on people all around the
world.
Zero in.
Try to keep track of the terrorists.
Sometimes you hit the daughter and son.
That's wrong.
Wife.
But you know how much goes into being able
to generate that kind of unmanned aerial vehicle?
And yet when it comes to dealing with poverty
or reform the prison industrial complex.
Lower priority.
Not on the radar screen.
You're gonna lose your democracy.
We have the wrong things on the radar screen.
That's part of our challenge.
>>Tavis Smiley: If I could add to that real
quick, I was thinking as Doc was talking.
Again about how important context is to all
of this.
Again, the first chapter of this book, Stacy,
lays out a portrait of poverty.
How we arrived at this place.
And in this moment, even when there's someone
in the White House, and Doc and I are very
clear in this book.
We think that President Obama is far better
than any alternative on the Right on these
issues.
We're gonna keep pushing him.
But he's far better than any alternative that
we see at the moment in the race.
That's our own assessment we've made.
And you may see that differently.
But we lay that out in this, in the book and
say that unapologetically.
Having said that, it's important to understand
that whether we're talking about people we
regard as our enemies, people who are pushing
an agenda that's antithetical to the best
interests of poor people, or we're talking
about persons we regard as our friends, we
have to remain vigilant.
Holding them accountable to the best interest
of the least among us.
Case in point.
I was on Bill Maher this Friday night on his
real time HBO show.
And Bill and I had a conversation about this.
So when you talk about the prison industrial
complex that Nava asked about with Dr. West.
The most damning thing that's happened to
poor people since Ronald Reagan and that nonsensical
so called war on drugs.
Reagan a Republican obviously.
But the worst thing since then was a Democrat
named Bill Clinton.
And Bill Clinton is my friend.
I know he ain't going to be happy when he
hears me say this.
But he's heard me say it before.
The most racist law that Bill Clinton ever
signed into, bill he ever signed into law,
was the crime bill.
Where you, we made as a part of the law the
fact that you had to get caught with 100 times
more powdered cocaine, this is what Doc was
suggesting.
You gotta get caught with 100 times more powdered
cocaine than crack cocaine to get the same
sentence.
100 times more powdered cocaine than crack
to get the same sentence.
We signed that into law during the Clinton
administration.
Negros was celebrating.
We all loved Bill Clinton.
He'd come to our churches and sing "We shall
overcome."
Know all the verses.
[laughter]
Verses, chorus, everything else.
I've stood with Clinton many times and when
the Negro national anthem, "Lift every voice
and sing" is sung.
He knows all the verses.
I know the first.
But he knows all the verses to "Lift every
voice and sing."
[laughter]
So he's a friend of the black community and
I love him and I'm not trying to demonize
him or cast aspersions.
I'm just saying that these politicians are
not perfect.
And even when they're our friends we have
to remain vigilant and diligent about holding
them accountable.
So that was a horrible law that Bill Clinton
signed.
And so you know, we've had to deal with that
for all these years so so many of the consequences
that Nava was asking about and Doc responded
to had to do with this crime bill that we
let Bill Clinton and Congress get away with
signing during his term.
That's on the prison industrial complex.
Back to poverty, women and children falling
faster into poverty I've said now for the
fifth time than any other group in our society.
Why is that Tavis?
Well, that is the case in part because 15
years ago Bill Clinton signed a so-called
"welfare reform" bill.
We refer to it as a welfare "deform" bill.
But he signed a welfare reform bill.
His intent was to move women from welfare
to work.
That's not exactly what's happened.
And now without going into all the particulars,
you see the exact opposite.
Where women don't have access to work and
they don't have access to the welfare to give
their children food to eat and medical care.
They don't have access to that program anymore.
'Cause we slashed the program so bad and changed
the rules and regulations 15 years ago.
Peter Edelman, the husband of Marion Wright
Edelman that Dr. West referenced earlier has
a wonderful book coming out a few weeks from
now, behind ours.
Called "So Rich, So Poor."
Peter Edelman famously resigned his high position
in the Clinton Administration in protest over
that law.
Peter Edelman and myself and Dr. West and
others were saying then, "This is going to
be bad for the country."
Took us 15 years to finally get to the point
now where the analysis and the data has been
done.
It didn't quite work out.
The New York Times last Sunday.
Sunday before last.
Front page, above the fold.
Major story, the New York Times.
15 years later, look at the carnage that's
been done as a result of that welfare bill.
This was a guy who we liked.
A guy who we supported and voted for and loved
and held hands with and sang "Kumbayah."
And he did a lot of wonderful things, don't
get me wrong.
But I'm just saying, again, making the point.
You gotta stay vigilant.
Even when they are your friends.
Even when they are of your political persuasion.
Even you are supporting them, and giving them
your money and giving them your vote and campaigning
for them.
You still gotta stay on 'em.
Because left to their own devices and the
people around them, they won't measure up.
And that's why, in this era, poverty again
is the issue of our time.
That we have to address, no matter who's in
the White House.
No matter who's running things on Capitol
Hill.
But I thought about that when you went into
that dissertation because, it's you know,
so much of this is about chickens coming home
to roost.
Years later.
And that's why poverty's just run amuck.
But anyway, I digress.
>>Stacy: So before we take this last question
from the audience, I wanna go a little bit
deeper on that.
'cause you bring up this concept.
And this is what you're getting at.
This fundamental fairness.
>>Cornel West: Mm.
Yes.
>>Tavis Smiley: Yes.
>>Stacy: So there's an inequity and there
needs to be a shift.
And talk about what that shift means and who
should be responsible for that shift.
Talk about lobbying.
And organizations.
Talk about what this fairness looks like.
Is it motherhood and apple pie?
Or is it real?
>>Cornel West: I think it has to do with courage.
And taking a risk.
We need more non-conformity in the culture.
>>Tavis Smiley: Ah.
>>Cornel West: 'Cause we live in a culture
where everything is up for sale.
Everybody's up for sale.
Things like integrity and dignity and magnanimity
ought to be beyond any kind of market price.
But if the conformity is so powerful that
people are just fearful of telling the truth
and bearing witness, because they're concerned
about careers rather than their callings.
Or their professions rather than their vocations.
Then you lose any source for the democratic
awakening that needs to take place.
'cause again, this is a citizen's affair.
And again, we speak as citizens.
We're citizens in democratic experiment.
We're concerned about its imperial side.
We're concerned about its racist, sexist and
classist side.
And homophobic side.
Anti-Semitic side.
Anti-Arab, anti-Muslim side.
But we know there's some good folk and some
good things in the democratic experiment.
That's what we stand for you see.
And there's always jazz and the blues.
Which is always comforting.
And Bruce Springsteen out there.
You know, the white blues brother out there
doing his magnificent thing with wrecking
balls.
But what we're saying is that if we don't
give this a sense of urgency, then just like
1861, lose your democracy.
Unless folk came through.
Just like 1930s, you lose it.
1960s, you can lose it.
Each time we were able to come through strongly.
Can we come through this time?
It's very much up to the younger generation.
I'm old-school.
He's old-school.
[laughter]
You all.
Many of you are new-school.
Its' a beautiful thing to see.
I'm not discriminating against the older brothers
and sister of all color.
Here with the grey.
[laughter]
But it's going to be a younger generation
affair.
And that's when we say who, they're gonna
lead us very much like the best of Occupy.
I know he's got a question.
>>Stacy: Alright.
Last question.
>>Male #2: Alright.
Great.
Well thank you both for being here.
My name is Daniel Sanderson.
And you both made a lot of keen, poignant
points about poverty.
Particularly with respect to new poverty.
And how that will or can threaten our democracy
in the future.
I guess what I'd like to hear a little bit
more about is, are there particular aspects
of our democracy that you feel are especially
threatened?
Is it the right to vote?
Is it something like political stability?
What are your thoughts on that?
>>Cornel West: You wanna respond for that?
>>Tavis Smiley: Well, I think it's all of
the above.
It's more of a smorgasbord for me.
>>Cornel West: it's a good question.
>>Tavis Smiley: it's a very good question.
>>Cornel West: Yeah.
>>Tavis Smiley: At the moment, since you raised
it.
The voting rights of people of color and poor
people are particularly threatened.
I'm glad to see that there is some conversation
about this on the radio and on the television.
And some persons have been out front about
this.
And we talk about this on our radio program,
Smiley and West as well.
But that does concern me.
Particularly because we are in an election
year.
The persons who are being targeted.
The persons who are having to jump through
all kinds of hoops.
Republicans, and I'm not trying to cast aspersion,
these are Republican sponsored bills.
Those are the facts.
Across the country where they're trying to
deny and take away and make the hurdle so
high for you to get into a booth just to cast
your vote.
There's a reason why there, these policies,
programs, and bills are becoming laws in certain
states.
Impacting certain communities.
And we all know what we're talking about here.
So that's one aspect that does particularly
concern me.
We raised that issue in the text.
But it is so fascinating and again, we're
out of time here.
But there's so many issues that we raise in
the book.
Where you can just see how the body politic
punishes, demonizes, criminalizes poor people.
And it's again, about highlighting those things.
About being aggressive in pushing back on
those things.
But for me, I'll let Doc give his own answer.
But for me at the moment, of the list you
just mentioned, the thing that I'm most concerned
about, again given where we are right now,
is this attack on voting rights in this country.
That is a particular aspect of democracy that
poor people are being particularly punished
by.
That legislation is not just, it's punitive
and pejorative where poor people are concerned.
>>Cornel West: Yes and I'm concerned about
the moral and spiritual dimension of our democracy.
You see, when citizens feel as if they're
hopeless and helpless, impotent, that they
donít make a difference, that the public
interest is defined in such a way that nobody
really cares about their suffering.
Or their wounds and their bruises.
That's the history of black folk for a long
time.
Right?
In the body politic, but civically dead.
No real rights.
Nobody respect.
Right.
That you say, "Well, how can a democracy survive
when you have large numbers and not just black
folk now.
We're talking about poor folk across the board,
you see.
They don't make a difference?"
Well, that reinforces narcissism, addiction,
self medication, escape.
All of the various forms of mass culture.
And all the little tricky techniques of trying
to get people pacified.
Because their pain is so overwhelming and
they figure they can do very little about
it.
Alcoholism.
Sex addiction.
We go on and on and on as ways people have
to deal with their wounds.
When people feel as if they can't really have
an impact on their world.
They can't lift their voices as they were,
as it were.
That's very dangerous.
That's very very dangerous.
And I think part of the prophetic tradition
that we try to enact in our own feeble way
is to call, make a call for the kind of awakening.
To say "You do make a difference.
And when you organize and mobilize, people
can see you make a difference.
And people care."
Well to do people do care about working and
poor people if they enact certain kinds of
efforts to promote certain kinds of policies.
To public interest and so on.
>>Male #2: Right.
>>Cornel West: So to give people a sense of,
yes, we all in this thing together.
And we either hang together or we hang separately.
>>Male #2: Thank you.
>>Stacy: Thank you.
>>Cornel West: Thank you for your question.
>>Stacy: We're ready to end.
We are all in this together.
Thank you for participating
>>Cornel West: Thank you, thank you.
You are wonderful.
Thank you.
>>Stacy: Joining us here at Google.
>>Cornel West: Absolutely.
>>Stacy: Participating and allowing our listeners
on YouTube to get a little bit of a glimpse
into "The Rich and The Rest of Us."
And giving us all a call to action on what
we can do as participants in this economy.
And caring about people.
Thank you for being here.
>>Tavis Smiley: Thank you Stacy.
[applause]
>>Cornel West: Thank you Stacy.
Thank you very much.
[applause continues]
>>Tavis Smiley: That was wonderful.
Wonderfully done.
>>Stacy: Thank you.
Thank you.
[modern instrumental music]